all right Ali yes Ali were you from
originally where'd you grow up
Alaska Alaska yes really and tell me
what you show that he had both your
parents growing up you know I had my mom
and my dad was around till I was two and
then he disappeared from my life until
first time I saw him again was when I
was 14 okay then how was your childhood
well on the outside looking in I had
everything all the opportunities my
grandparents were well-to-do but my mom
was a cocaine addict until I was eight
and then she got clean but um my sister
she's four and a half years older than
me she she was sexually molested by her
campfire teacher that the school had for
the summer put on and quite badly and so
you know kids you know how they cope
with that they reenact things and so
from the time I was three years old
tell nine years old I was sexually
molested by my sister and any
neighborhood kids that she could involve
you know uh-huh very sexually molested
in this one for how long from three to
nine three nine mhm the end reason it
stopped when I was nine is cuz that's
when my sister ran away from home and
she became a prostitute where she today
she today is in North Pole Alaska and
she has kids and she's doing a lot
better she still has a lot of issues
she's you know drug addict like we all
are in my family pretty much but uh but
she's not really prostituting anymore
for the most part but you know for drugs
you know she might whatever you know she
does what she does right but um
she was always like the outcast in the
family but and I was considered the good
kid but I was the one who was always in
jail you know I've spent half my life in
prison I I wanted to be self-sufficient
well running back up so at 11 years old
I got addicted to cocaine I'd snort it
and then by 12 years old I was addicted
to crack cocaine gonna do see to that
that would be one of my uncle's friends
at a Christmas party at my grandmother's
house and that was Mike shadley was his
name and we would sit down to the
basement and played pool you know I
loved hanging out with my aunt's my
uncles cuz they'd let me drink and stuff
you know it was a different time back in
the 80s you know and so by 12 years old
I was addicted to crack and I couldn't
function with kids my age in school so I
dropped out of school in seventh grade
and so I have basically a seventh grade
education I did go back when I was 22
and got my GED but I really have no book
smarts yeah from that so where'd you
like to go from there
from there I moved out of my mom's house
and I went we I grew up in Fairbanks
Alaska and when I was 8 my mom got clean
off drugs and we moved to Anchorage and
so when I was 12 and I moved out of my
mom's house I went back to Fairbanks to
stay with my grandmother and I had a
horse and everything and but I was
addicted to drugs and I couldn't cope
there so I took off from there and I met
this guy Ryan and we started going out
he was a few years older than me and he
had his own place and he was weird you
know he didn't physically abuse me like
hitting me all the time babe he would do
weird stuff if I wouldn't have sex with
him he'd [ __ ] my legs you know he would
put plastic bags over my head and poke
holes in it and just to watch me suffer
he would do really weird stuff to me but
I got away from him and I went back to
Anchorage to be with my mom and I was
like 15 at this time and my mom my mom
and my stepdad did ballroom in Latin
dancing so I grew up doing that too and
my mom had a a junior team and they
would travel all over the states and
stuff competing and stuff and my mom
also had a dance peril business and it's
called showstoppers dance where and so
she had me working for her while her
junior team and them were I think they
were in Paris or something for a dance
competition and my sister came by and we
emptied out my mom's cash register and
we went and got a bunch of crack and we
were partying at the house and my sister
went outside for some odd reason at like
4:00 in the morning and I heard her
screams went running out and there was
Ryan and he snatched me up and took me
to Valdez Alaska and for like two weeks
he had me in a tent in Valdez Alaska at
a campground and it was my birthday and
I wanted to call my mom and tell her I
was alive because nobody knew what
happened to me and he got upset by that
and he was drunk and he put a gun to my
head and somebody seen it and called the
cops so for like three hours they tried
to get him to take the gun away from me
but he didn't he cocked it and pulled
the trigger and it jammed and so they
took him to jail and from there my life
I ran away to Hawaii and in Hawaii I you
know I'm a crackhead and they didn't
have much crack there they had ice
they're about to you know so I started
doing meth and I quit smoking crack and
I just I started going from Maui Oahu I
would I would
you know a couple ounces and go back to
Maui and sell them and then go back you
know and I had a boyfriend who was and
he was on work furlough which is you're
in prison but you can go out of during
the day to work and he's much older than
me 18 years older than me and his name
was Al and I'm his actual name is
Llewellyn he's Hawaiian and one day when
I was in Oahu picking up my stuff I was
pregnant by this time with my first
child I was I was 19 or 28 by this time
and the guy seeing a picture of Al and
my wallet and he was like why do you
have a picture of this guy in a wall and
he said that's the father of my baby and
he's like oh [ __ ] he's like no no no I'm
gonna put you back on a plane and from
this moment on we don't know each other
and I'm like why
and he's like because I don't want to
get my throat slit and I was like what
and I had no idea at the time that the
guy I was pregnant by was a huge very
well-known drug dealer in Hawaii
and I just had no idea you know I
thought that I was something but I was
nothing in any way so he got out of jail
and my life with him was crazy he he was
a huge drug dealer and and basically I
stayed holed up in a in a house you know
pregnant and I never seen him his
runners would bring me food and whatnot
and I was kind of just going crazy but I
I was crazy for him you know um he tried
to you know run me down or I tried to
rent him went down one time when he's
trying to get away from me but basically
the cops because they knew who I was
with any time I was walking down the
street they would literally arrest me
take me to jail for no reason and they
couldn't hold me more than three days
but they would interrogate me and try to
get me
to give him up when I gave birth to my
kid I I gave birth with cops in my
delivery room you know he couldn't come
to the hospital and then they took my
baby away from me all because of who he
was and and I had no chance of getting
my kid back which I didn't know at the
time but they didn't call I didn't want
to tell my family that I lost my kid so
I lied and I acted like I had him but my
parents my mom and my grandmother came
to Hawaii to surprise me one day and
meet the baby and they found me walking
down the street and I was probably like
90 pounds all strung out and they wanted
to know where the baby was and that's
when I told him I lost it my grandmother
had this do sue the state of Hawaii to
get him back because they had an
adoption ring going on and she did get
him and she has them to this day when I
was in Hawaii my baby's daddy was wanted
obviously and I wanted to get off the
island with him somehow and I just
started thinking gosh I could just like
make you an ID or something you know and
I found out that I had this like amazing
knack for making IDs
I could make IDs so I started making
ideas and birth certificates and social
security cards and anything else that I
could recreate you know and in the
meantime he got busted and and there's a
huge story behind that too but I I guess
I don't need to go into all that but the
cops on Maui were dirty and
I had internal affairs when I was in
jail come try to speak to me to find out
what I knew but I didn't know anything
at the time and find out till later on
that my baby's dad had some sort of
indisputable evidence against the police
department bringing in drugs making
contract killings things like that and
he worried you know that we might have
to go into hiding and stuff you know
because
when they were trying to catch him and
arrest him
one cop in particular his name was rocky
Silva he would shoot to kill like I mean
if he found us he would start shooting
and there look we didn't have to have a
gun or anything
he raped one girl with a nightstick in
the butt thinking it was me just because
you know he had a vendetta against al
for having this evidence or whatever a
rookie cop was the one who busted my
baby's dad which is why he's still alive
right now but he's still in prison to
this day it's been 18 years and he's
still in prison he he has four
first-degree attempted-murder two four
police officers and 25 first-degree
assault and and like I said internal
affairs came to visit me when I was in
jail because they wanted to know what I
knew about this evidence he had which I
didn't know anything about thank God
because they'd probably be dead right
now but the reason I went to prison is
because when I was trying to make ideas
for us to get off the island and I found
out that I was really good at it I
started thinking wow I could do
something with this so I Walmart know it
was came out at the time had this thing
they called instantaneous credit and you
could go in with a name social security
number and an address and you would find
out if you were good for credit and if
you were then you could shop for three
days with that receipt and tell the
actual card came in the mail so I would
go rob people's mailboxes for their
information and then I would go and I
had my little printer set up in my car
with my inverter you know to make IDs
right then and there if I applied for if
I got the credit so I would do that and
then I started finding checks in the
mail and I started doing that cuz you
can get cash back and write a check out
you know and
returned the item the next day and get
the cash back and and it just gradually
grew until I mean I was I I was rolling
in a 2002 Lexus and I was you know I was
21 years old I had a kid that I didn't
have because you know my grandmother was
at this time battling for him but I was
so strung out I just was out of control
but I when I got busted I became I they
made a new law just for me basically
because when they busted me all they
busted me with was a bunch of unopened
mail and actually a lot of people think
that's federal but it's not it's not
federal until you open the mail and
because it wasn't opened they really
didn't have much about a 30-day thing
that they could get me on but the girl
that I was busted with her statement
that she made got it to where they made
a whole new lot just for me a new
identity theft law which they say is
worse than you know manslaughter because
it's premeditated and it carries up to
20 years per count well I had 72 charges
of that so my first public pretender
public defender said I was gonna do 40
years flat period it was only 22 years
old I'd never been in jail for anything
other than I had one second-degree
assault which was bogus too while I was
with my baby's dad I we were robbed at
4:00 in the morning by three Samoan guys
and they came in beating us with bats I
was eight and a half months pregnant and
to make a long story short I slit one
guy's throat and I stabbed the other two
in the meantime the second guy got the
knife away from me and I grabbed it back
by the blade and I cut all my fingertips
off and so when the cops came and I was
standing there with the knife and there
was blood there was like a circle of
people all around me and all four of us
went to the emergency room me and the
three guys that robbed us because we
were all we all had stab wounds
and I had passed out or something
because when I woke up I was handcuffed
to the bed and they didn't understand
why because I was I was at home I was
eight and a half months pregnant I was
tiny besides a big belly and I'm a
female and there's three huge Samoan
guys and I'm handcuffed to the bed and
I'm hearing them ask if they want to
press charges against me and thank God
they said no but I went to jail that
night and my baby's dad bailed me out
for 24,000 cash an hour later no no bail
bonds just twenty four thousand dollars
cash and I have a second degree on my
cell or assault on me on my record but
I've never been to court for that never
was convicted of it but I have it on my
record which is bogus you know the
reason that they took me to jail is
because of who my baby's dad was that's
the only reason you know rocky Silva was
the cop on duty that night they took me
to jail this is before my baby's dad was
wanted again right now he was just still
on probation or parole you know he had
just done ten years in jail so where was
i before I went back in time to that I
was talking about
oh yeah so I I gave birth to my son and
the delivery room with all the cops and
they're trying to get my baby's dad but
he didn't come to the hospital I lost my
baby that day my grandmother came she
was battling for the boy oh yeah and I
ended up in jail and I the second lawyer
because I fired that lawyer also said
the same thing I was looking at 40 to 60
years flat so my mom
I love her to death she's never judged
me she's always been right there for me
she had a fundraiser with her dance
students and they raised up $10,000 to
give me a real lawyer this whole time no
way really
my whole family was behind me and they
lost everything pretty much my
grandparents the money that they spent
to sue the state of Hawaii to get my son
pretty much killed their business that
they had for 55 years they eventually
had to shut down because they couldn't
afford it anymore
my mom had everything she had into
getting me a lawyer and which was great
you know my I only ended up getting
charged with five of those identity
thefts in the first degree and they
carried 20 years per count so that's 100
years plus five credit card thefts was
on her in 20 years it was what I got
with I I did get out of jail with with a
ten-year probation thing with the
stipulation that if I screwed up at all
within this 10-year period that I had to
go back and I would do no less than 50
years I added a 50 year mandatory
minimum sentence but the judge could
charge me anywhere from fifty two
hundred and twenty two years which was
my max sentence but no less well when I
got out of jail Maui didn't want me to
leave the island of Y but my my mom had
the mayor and the the chief of my tribe
I'm Native Alaskan at the basket Indian
Widgit tribe had them write letters
saying they couldn't legally hold me and
like some native to Alaska you know they
can't hold me there you know and if the
probation office was willing to take me
on then they couldn't legally keep me so
they gave me a 30-day travel pass in
which
had to convince Alaska to take me on as
a you know as a person on probation
overseeing it for Hawaii which they did
on the 27th day except me in the
meantime I put myself into treatment and
I I was okay for three years I graduated
treatment when not it was okay for three
years and then and then I screwed up and
started making IDS again started doing
drugs and this time I taught everybody
in Fairbanks how to make IDs and there
ended up being a huge male ring that
they tried to say that I was the
ringleader of but I beat that case and I
ended up going on a shopping spree with
my boyfriend in Anchorage and for three
days and it ended with me feeling like I
needed to go home cuz by this time I was
I was not going to probation not
checking in and I was wanted I wasn't
wanted to fugitive out of Hawaii at this
point and I knew I was screwed if I got
caught I was going back I was not gonna
do less than fifty years you know and
and so I was scared I wanted to go back
home and just stay holed up in my house
you know and my boyfriend for whatever
reason decided to publicly beat me up
and you know just pull me out of the car
and start wiping my ass and you know
somebody called the cops well on our way
to Fairbanks of course I made like four
IDs for him because all of the checks
that we had were in guys
his name's and it's not funny but it is
kind of funny I had a printer of course
you know in my car so I could print out
the IDs and whatnot and I had a sticker
which they used as evidence against me
on my printer just show that I had no
compassion or empathy for what I'd done
it said I don't feel like myself today
maybe I'm you and that's not funny but
it is but anyway so to make long story
short I I got busted and I had to do my
time in Alaska for this new identity
theft crime I got and before they
extradited me back to Hawaii I wouldn't
tell them my name when I got busted so
they booked me under Jane Doe but about
seven days later I don't know why it
took so long maybe their fingerprint
thing was broken or something but it
took them about a week to figure out who
I was but I heard when they said my last
name it was over for me so so I got new
charges in Alaska and then I was waiting
to be extradited back to Hawaii and I
did you know my three years in Alaska
and I was waiting to be extradited back
to Hawaii I talked to my lawyer in
Hawaii and he said that he had cut me a
deal for a 30-year flat sentence so I
gave my son up for adoption to my
grandmother cuz up until this time she
just had him I had not lost my parental
rights or anything but I gave him up for
adoption to her because I didn't think I
was gonna get out you know so for three
years I just mentally prepared myself to
not get out till I was an old person you
know so two weeks before I was supposed
to get extradited back to Hawaii the
in-house Pio comes up to me and tells me
she wants to talk to me in the office
and I thought oh my god they're gonna
take me early or something this is awful
you know and she says well what would
you do if you were to get out you know
today and they said why are you making
me tell you that I don't want to think
about that I don't want to think about
that you know I stopped taking visits
from anybody not family nothing I just
would call my son
the phone that was it I totally said
goodbye to the outside world you know
and I mentally had to prepare myself you
know it's a long time you know I like
being free I don't want to be locked up
in a cage like an animal anymore I get
really bad anxiety just thinking about
it really bad PTSD but but she made me
tell her anyway which I was upset about
but I told her and she's like well good
you have to go by exactly what you just
said because you're getting out in two
weeks I said what she's like why he's
giving you a second chance and so I
don't know why but my first reaction was
not happy I was probably in shock
obviously but I was actually
disappointed like I was like what you
know I just I gave up my kid I you know
what do you mean I'm getting out you
know I was so excited to go to Ikes I
could smoke cigarettes in jail there um
stupid stuff but it took about 24 hours
and then it hit me
and I was like oh my god I'm getting out
you know and I called my grandparents
and he told them and my grandmother was
like oh no she's like what she's like
you do so well in jail don't get me
wrong I'm glad you're getting out but
you excel in prison and you as soon as
you have your own you know free will you
just screw up and I'm like wow she's
like and you don't just screw up a
little bit you screw up bad and I'm like
yeah so one of the the people that I had
hurt doing identity theft sorry to back
up a little bit in Hawaii when I first
started doing these crimes I didn't care
who I did it to you know I I was there
to take your money and a lady came I had
several people almost a hundred people
come take the stand at my arraignment
just to make sure I wasn't getting out
of jail and one of the ladies was a lady
that I remembered very well at the time
spending her money I'd put her on the
street and she was a single mother of
five her husband had died and that has
stayed with me forever because I just
couldn't believe I did that somebody so
when I did start doing identity theft
again I this time decided that I was
going to stock the obituaries and hit
dead people instead because I didn't
want just screw up anybody who was alive
and although that sounds really morbid
now to me at the time I felt like I was
being very kind and I justified it by
the fact that I wouldn't just do any
dead person I picked undead people that
didn't have any next of kin who's my
name is pretty much in probate which I
consider a black hole for the government
you know to take your money so I didn't
feel like I was doing anything very
wrong you know I felt like I felt like
our nation or our America or whatever we
we idolize Robin Hood and things like
that but yet you grow up and be like
that and you want you get in trouble you
know what I mean
so I felt like I was Robin Hood robbing
from the rich and helping out the poor
because I was very very generous I mean
I I liked buying people stuff because
it's how I got a lot of my self-worth
was giving things to people made me
happy
and so
the government didn't like that they
don't like you stealing their money so
yeah so anyway I just I decided this
time when I got out of jail I wasn't
gonna do that again I wasn't gonna do
identity theft ever again you know
because when I got sober the more that I
thought about the fact that I you know
would stock the obituaries and then
literally go rob a dead person's house
was pretty disgusting you know really
disgusting and I didn't really like
myself very much for that so I thought
the best way that I could make amends to
these people and these dead people that
I hurt was to never do it again
and so I I you know pretty much you know
I decided I wanted to join the military
but they wouldn't let me
they were like hell no you're a thief
you're the worst of the worst you know
you can't do it and I didn't just stop
there I mean for years I went in and I
just drilled them I wanted to join the
military I wanted to do something
different my life I wanted to be a
better person but they wouldn't let me
and it seems like as much as I've tried
to change my life the only thing that I
can do is deal drugs or I could go sell
my ass you know because this thing about
you know them you know make you know
changing your life and doing things
better when you get out of jails
[ __ ] they they label you a felon and
you're [ __ ] you know I can't do
anything that has to do with money I
can't work in a bingo hall I can't do
anything like that I can do construction
that's the only field of work that
doesn't judge me in my past and I can't
even work with old people I can't really
do anything being a thief is really
considered worse than murder
and
when it comes to you know society and
working in stuff they really rather have
a murderer than a thief working for them
it's just the truth you know which I get
it I get it but uh but so pretty much
what I've done all these years is I've
you know dealt drugs cuz I don't want to
sell my ass because for me you know my
sister was a prostitute for years I
watched her get beat drugged just
terrible things and I don't know if she
even likes herself very much you know
but a couple years ago my mom got sick
with cancer and she takes care of my my
daughter I have three kids I'm the
youngest one I gave up for adoption
I actually had him for my aunt I wasn't
gonna do the pregnant when I found out I
was pregnant I wasn't gonna have it I
was gonna have an abortion but I didn't
want to my aunt really wanted to have a
baby so I asked her if she wanted to
have a baby with me you know she wanted
to have a baby and so I had my baby for
her and it's kind of crazy because he he
came out looking just like her which is
weird because his whole sister looks
nothing like him and me and the dad will
have dark brown hair and brown eyes and
he came out blonde with hazel eyes you
know and she's blond hair blue eyed so
it was just kind of weird he looks just
like her but my I have an 18 year old
son my Hawaiian son
and then I have my daughter patience it
was ten and she loves me to pieces I've
broken her heart quite a few times
because I leave but I don't want to drag
her through the mud I'm a heroin addict
I shoot up heroin I smoke crack and I do
meth and I I want to be a good mom like
you know I talked to my daughter every
single day but a few years back my mom
got sick with cancer and she lost her
job and ultimately lost her house which
she didn't tell me at first she was not
telling anybody in the family about it
but I came back to Alaska because I had
I travel I'm a Romer I'd went to Seattle
and then I came here to California and
and I just missed my kids and I left I
left my ex here that I'd been with for
eight years running around chasing him
all over the world I left him and I went
back to my family and my mom pulls up to
this shabby apartment building and I'm
like what are we doing here she's like
this is home and I'm like whoa what
happened to our house you know cuz my
mom used to have you know she had two
businesses and she was a travel agent
for 14 years I mean she was well-to-do
she was she had a condo in Hawaii I mean
she was doing big things you know and so
it was very shocked to see that she was
living in a tiny little one-bedroom
nasty little shabby apartment complex
lost the house and everything lost her
really well-paying job and so she has
cancer for the third time and I had
saved up a little bit of money and when
I went home I gave her all of it to put
towards the rent because they found out
she was quite a few months behind
we paid $2,500 and landlord assured me
that she wouldn't be kicked out but
seven days later we got into big she
knows us and I had to move into a tent
with my mom and my daughter and I always
promised my mom that if she ever got
sick I would take care of her but I just
did so bad with my life early on that
I'm unable to do that now so I I decided
because I have a flagging license in
Washington I decided to go back well
learning back up before I do that before
I decided to go back to Washington I
didn't know what to do for my mom we had
no food we're living in a tent so I
resorted back to old things I know how
to get money I went and I did some
mailboxes and
I did a couple checks which right now I
didn't have any idea I asked my mom okay
in the meantime I was doing oddball jobs
on Craigslist I was cleaning houses and
stuff you know and I went really was
doing that that's legit people would pay
me new checks but this time work was
slow they told my mom I had gotten a job
I went and got a check out of the
mailbox and I lifted the ink and wrote
it out to me and I wrote it out to her I
didn't tell her the truth until now she
knows the truth because she's going to
court for it because they think that
that she knew about it and my mom has
never been in trouble before so now she
has cancer she takes care of my daughter
and now she's in trouble with the law
for a felony charge and I want to go
back and turn myself in but she won't
let me because she knows that if I go
down again I'm gonna be doing a lot of
years and we don't know how much time
she has left and so I promised her that
I would go to Washington and I would get
a flagging job and I would help her I
would send money until I can get into an
apartment and I would send for them well
about two months after I got to
Washington and I was working everything
my flagging license expired so I
couldn't work anymore I had to get a new
one well it used to be really easy you
just paid $55 and went to an eight-hour
class and you got your flagging card now
you have to enroll in college to get it
so I'm a procrastinator needless to say
I found an easier way I was living in
what they call the jungle its tent city
in Seattle and I know a lot of people
there and one of one of the big dealers
there he was my good friend he said look
you can partner up with me and um you
know you send here my money so I was
setting my mom like a hundred dollars a
day of dealing drugs and he got busted
he went to jail so its territorial there
you know I was a white girl in there all
Vietnamese pretty much and when he went
to jail
the Vietnamese basically put me in a
room and they all had a meeting where
they decided who was gonna take the dope
and the money from me and they told me I
couldn't work anymore which I still did
work but I had them shooting guns in my
tent 2:00 in the morning things like
that threatening me that I had to stop
and so I I stopped you know at least
dealing out of the jungle I'd walk
around and deal here and there but I
couldn't make any money that way so I
went back to stealing not identities or
anything like that but I'd steal from
the store go sell it to the Chinese and
then I would still send my mom money
every day and I still do any anything I
hustle up every day every single day any
bit of money I get I sent half of it to
her even if it's 15 dollars I sent her
ten and my goal is at this point to get
into a into housing and I had to get out
of Washington because I'm I I basically
I'm wanted for escape there I'm on the
run there
I had DFC charges from years ago and I
skipped out and when I got back they you
know found me blah blah blah anyway
they're charging me with escape and in
Alaska is unwarranted therefore
organized retail theft and fraud so both
of those are extraditable charges so I'm
scared I traveled here under a fake name
but I had to get out of Washington
because I'll face I'm not afraid to face
my charges I know that I did wrong
I know that I have to be accountable for
that I'm not saying that I don't want to
be I will you know I will lay in the bed
that I made but I want to get my mom and
my daughter taken care of before that
happened because I don't know how much
longer she has that's what I want to do
so I came here because I thought I could
probably get in housing you know a
little you know relatively quickly here
because they know that they're under
pretty much tremendous pressure to get
the homeless off the streets here you
know so that's what I do every day I
hustle up some money I send it to my mom
and in the meantime I'm trying to get
into housing I came at the really wrong
time because of the stupid coronavirus
this coronavirus is making it so that I
can't really do anything everything's
closed you know for housing and stuff so
I'm just waiting for that to happen
yeah that's right Mac and a lot of stuff
in between all that happen but I don't
even I don't even know where to start
it's quite a story so you're you're on
the run right now from so who'd be
looking for you
Alaska and Washington state I mean if
they were to find you you wouldn't I
would be in trouble I wouldn't I'm
looking at 10 to 15 years yeah
and putting this video out won't get you
in trouble well it could if they find me
I mean I suppose you know but it's move
around as you said you know I mean
Facebook everybody knows where I met
it's not like I'm hiding that much I
don't like running you know I'm not
really I am running but I'm not I mean I
don't want to say you know here's where
I'm staying at here you know come and
get me but but you know it is what it is
I guess well we thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah
thank you
what do you think in your childhood was
the the most powerful factor and leading
you down this path that's a good
question I had a lot of things that
happened to me that were traumatic and
at the same time I had a really good
life you know I had horses I did I did I
competed ballroom in Latin dancing I had
a lot of really great things but then
like I said times were different in the
80s you know I also had uncles and aunts
and family members that used drugs dealt
drugs screw drugs and I wanted I wanted
to be part of it all you know I wanted
to be part of it all and I liked it I
liked the bad stuff I liked I had fun
with it you know
I guess I'm just it was just always a
bad seed I guess you know but in a good
way like I'm a loving good person I have
a good heart but I really like I I'm a
street person - I like the streets you
know it's weird but probably the biggest
thing was the fact that I had drugs
readily available and people willing to
give them to me at a young age and I
wanted to be part of what they were
doing you know my aunts and uncles were
cool man
it was beautiful my uncle it was
handsome you know and they had lots of
friends you know tons of friends and I
just wanted to be part of all of it you
know where my grandparents lived in
Fairbanks there's not very many kids in
that neighborhood they're kind of the
boonies and so what there was a lot of
was teenagers drugs and partying and
like Alaska I don't want to raise my
daughter or my kids there my son is
already done for you okay he just turned
18 he just got out of prison he's been
in prison since he was 13 so he's
already following down my footsteps you
know and I don't want that for my
daughter in Alaska and they know that
drugs are everywhere you go but in
Alaska there's not a whole lot of
diversity you know there's a lot of
darkness a lot of cold and a lot of
depression and a lot of drugs you know
so people and the kids they that's what
they get into there you know unless
you're really you know I don't know
unless you have some amazing support
maybe with your family
do you not but I I think at least 70% of
the kids probably fall into drugs there
and I don't think that my kids will be
any different my daughter might be
because because she's had a rough tough
little life you know she's just the best
hearted little soul in the world and she
I don't believe she will get into drive
ever because she's watched me in
Hallett's you know and she loves me to
death
but she knows what my problem is you
know she knows that I have a drug issue
and someday maybe she's gonna hate me
for that and I hope not but I wouldn't
blame her if she did because I've always
you know it seems like I put drugs first
but I really am just I am putting her in
the in the kids first I I put my last
senator first by giving him to a mom I
know wanted him and it would make him
feel like he was a gift to her you know
like he was you know I don't want to
ruin my kids his life is the way I have
but I have but with my child it is
definitely probably because the drugs
were readily available very readily
available and it's depressing nothing to
do in Alaska very cold then very dark
except for in the summertime then it's
light all the time that all right Ali
well thank you so much for talking to me
thank you and good luck with is
everything everything it is thank you
you